in clark county have spent the majority
of the school year attending classes
virtually but there have been exceptions
one being at adelson education campus
with more on that we're joined by the
principal of aec
dr camille mchugh dr mchugh thanks for
joining us today
thank you so much for having me big week
today is
graduation at aec this was a special
year for your school
yeah it really was you know we're so
excited tonight is graduation
and we'll be celebrating the
commencement of the class of 2021.
back in august we got started with a
return to face-to-face education
our students and our teachers were live
in the classroom in our brick and mortar
facility
and we held our code protocols all year
and now 10 months later
they're graduating so we're so excited
to be able to celebrate this uh
time-honored tradition
it is amazing that you were able to do
that without interruption
is it because of the dedication that
everybody had to uh
following the protocol yeah it certainly
was
you know it really took a lot of
teamwork
the students their families the faculty
our coveted response team our nurse our
office manager
and i would also say that it was a great
partnership with the southern nevada
health district
dr chad kingsley and his team were
amazing partners they provided us the
guidance we needed
and also helped us troubleshoot some
challenges when they arose so
all of us working together allowed us to
be in person
and it was a lot of hard work that
brought us to this day and now at the
end of the school year
yeah congratulations to you for that
what do you see moving forward
on your campus you know
we are going to continue to do what
we've always done well and that's
teach wonderful children teach them
content teach them values
and help kids grow from children into
responsible young adults so
as we head into the summer we're going
to conduct a summer camp and then next
school year we'll be back to business as
usual our
enrollment continues to grow and we're
looking forward to welcoming in
our students who've been with us and
many more new students too yeah
here we hear so many great things about
what's going on at your school
in fact you had a partnership going back
to the cobia topic
you had a partnership with the southern
nevada health district
as you guys served as a model school for
other schools
looking to open their doors to students
time
that's exactly right you know we had
spent the previous summer developing
coveted protocols
we implemented them throughout the year
and it was important not only to
hold to those protocols but also to be
nimble and flexible
and react as needed as situations arose
so again it was our team and it was our
partnership
with snhd that allowed us to do that so
people want to learn more about your
school can they visit campus or
how would you invite them to learn more
so we certainly invite you to visit our
website
um also you can call and you can meet up
with our admissions representatives and
come in for a tour
after hours and we'd love to welcome
anybody who's interested in
learning more about us or perhaps
attending our school to come and visit
dr mchugh thanks for your time
congratulations on a great year
thank you so much take care there is the
website that we
were talking about adelsoncampus.org
along with the phone number 702-255-4500